لا فادا مراسل الجزيره في لبنان بان قضيه
تحقيق اجل جلسه الاستماع الى افاده حاكم
مصر في لبنان رياض سلامه بحضور محققين
اوروبيين الى غدا الخميس بسبب عدم حضور
سلامه وطلبت وزاره العدل اللبنانيه من
القضاء توقيف سلامه وشقيقه ومساعدته وحجز
املاكهم وتجميد حساباتهم المصرفيه من
جانبه قال محامي سلامه ان استدعاء موكله
الى جلسه تحقيق اوروبي وانتهاك للسياده
اللبنانيه واضاف انه يمكن للسلطات
اللبنانيه ارجاء التعاون مع التحقيقات
الاوروبيه بسبب تعارضها مع تحقيقاتها
معنى من بيروت يوسف دياب الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد يوسف ما الذي يعنيه هذا
الاستدعاء للتحقيق مع رياض سلامه حكم مصرف
لبنان في اطار التحقيق الاوروبي
نعم يعني نحن نعرف انه منذ اواخر شهر
كانون الثاني يناير الماضي بدات بدات
الوفود القضائيه الاوروبيه بالتوافد الى
لبنان
لاستجواب شخصيات مصرفيه
واقتصاديه وعلى راسها حاكم مصرف لبنان في
اطار تحقيق تجريه السلطات الاوروبيه حول
وجود او توفر شبهات على تبييض اموال من
خلال تحويلات ماليه حصلت من حساب رياض
سلامي وشقيقي رجع من مصرف بيروت ومن مصارف
تجاريه الى مصارف اوروبيه في الخارج بناء
على هذه الشبهات وبناء على معطيات تفيد
بان للقضاء الاوروبي بان مصادر هذه
الاموال قد تكون غير شرعيه بدات تحقيق
الاوروبي في هذا المجال وجرى الاستماع الى
عشره اشخاص بينهم اصحاب مصارف لبنانيه
ومسؤولين مصرف لبنان اليوم نحن دخلنا
الجوله الثانيه من هذه التحقيقات هناك
اليوم قاضيه فرنسيه موجوده في لبنان
بالاضافه الى وفود من لوكسمبرج وبلجيكا
والمانيا كانوا بصدد الاستماع الى رياض
سلامه اليوم لم يمثل رياض سلامه اليوم
امام هؤلاء القضاه باعتبار انه ربما مذكره
الى القضاء اللبناني قدم مذكره وقال بان
جلسه تحقيق اوروبي هو انتهاك للسياده
اللبنانيه هل هذا المعطى قضائيا يمكن ان
يحيل دون امتثاله امام جلسه التحقيق غدا
ايضا
اطلاقا يعني لم يتاخر جواب قاضي التحقيق
والنيابه العامه التمييزيه اكثر من عشر
دقائق كان الجواب بان المذكره التي تقدم
بها رياض سلامه تخالف الواقع قالوا له او
ابلغوه في الجواب بان وجود قضاه اوروبيين
باطار تنفيذ استنابات قضائيه ياتي في اطار
التعاون القضائي ما بين لبنان والقضاء
الاوروبي كما انه ياتي منسجما مع اتفاقيه
مكافحه الفساد التي وقع عليها لبنان في
العام 2008 لذلك اعتقد اليوم ان رياض
سلامه
مجبرا على الحضور
غدا والقضات الاوروبيه ان يحضر سيد دياب
غدا الى جلسه التحقيق بالرغم من تداخل
السياسي بملفات عديده ابرزها القضاء في
لبنان
لنكن واقعين اليوم انا سالت بعض القضاه
الذين كانوا ينتظرون وجود رياض سلامه ولم
يحضر قالوا بانه تبلغ شخصيا عبر وكيله
القانوني بضروره المتول غدا ووافق على
المثول اذا لم يحضر رياض سلامي وهذا ايضا
امر متوقع هذا يعني ان هناك جهات في لبنان
ربما تكون متضرره من حضور الرياض سلامي
هذه هذا التحقيق وبالتالي لديها مصلحه
بتغيبي اي معنى بمعنى ان هناك غطاء سياسي
لعدم مثوله امام القضاه الاوروبيين
والقضات اللبنانيين وبالتالي هذا يرتب
مسؤوليات قانونيه على رياض سلامي ليس فيه
الدخل اللبناني ولكن في اوروبا بمعنى ان
القضاه الاوروبيين اليوم موجودين حتى يوم
الجمعه اذا لم يحضر رياض سلامي ولم يمثل
امامهم عندها سيعود القضاه الى بلادهم
وسيوجهون الاتهام من هناك الى رياض سلامي
ويطلب ون من لبنان ان يتعامل مع رياض
سلامي على اساس انه شخصيه مدعى عليها من
قبل الفضاء الاوروبي من بيروت يوسف دياب
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا على المشاركه
معنا